bonjour fatima benomar merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
pour parler donc de cette manifestation
de soutien aux palestiniens
manifestation interdite
raison invoquée les débordements en
parfois graves on l'a vu dans le sujet
lors d'une manifestation datant de 2014
en soutien aux palestiniens pour vous
fatima benomar est il légitime de la
part du ministre de l'intérieur de
justifier sa décision de l'interdire par
des faits qui datent d'il ya sept ans
non c'est très très grave les mêmes
listes y internationale est monté au
créneau pour dire que c'était absolument
injustifié c'est quand même incroyable
que dans la capitale de la france qui a
incarné pendant des décennies une
position courageuse défense du droit
international les parisiens ne puisse
pas aller dans leur rue manifester en
soutien aux palestiniens contre leurs
occupations et par ailleurs j'étais à la
manifestation de 2014 ou qu'il ya sept
ans par rapport à mort aux juifs
il n'a jamais été prouvé et confirmé que
ça avait été fait que ça avait été
prononcée il a dit que j'allais des
reflets dorés galles et j'entends bien
des des personnes dire mort ou vif
comment cette vidéo nous les attendons
je veux bien que vous devez difficile
mais en tout cas ce que je sais c'est
que luce et service d'ordre à l'époque
avait viré tous les éléments qui créent
de des incidents antisémites la justice
serait saisie et d'ailleurs s'il y avait
eu vraiment des personnes qui avaient
proféré de telles choses mais en tout
cas ce que je peux dire c'est que ça
devient extrêmement grave c'est en
france à paris on ne puisse pas
manifester parce que des individus
isolés crient des slogans qui lui
contreviennent à la loi
imaginez par exemple pourtant je suis
pas contre eux enfin je suis bien contre
leurs positions
si on interdisait les manifs pour tous
parce qu'il y avait des slogans qui
était homophobe
ça veut dire à ce prix seulement qu'il
faut interdire toute manifestation en
prévention de slogans qui m'engage pas
les organisations organisatrice et nous
ce que nous demandons dans ces
manifestations c'est tout simplement ce
que demande toute la communauté
internationale ont qu à chaque feu
on parle du conflit israélo palestinien
comme si les tensions n'étaient
existantes que pendant les affrontements
armés
or à chaque sens on appelle au calme
comme si on appelait au statu quo or le
calme
aujourd'hui c'est une occupation qui est
en soi un état violent il faut pas
oublier que le quotidien des territoires
occupés depuis 1967 c'est des expulsions
d'ailleurs l'onu vient de ressortir la
semaine dernière un texte pour condamner
les expulsions des palestiniens de leurs
maisons dans ces territoires occupés
c'est le couvre-feu select chez knight
et donc à chaque fois les tensions de
cet état devenu normal d'occupation
s'exacerbent et on ne commente à chaque
fois que quand cette exacerbation
explose donc nous ce qu'on demande ce
qu'on veut aller demander dans la rue et
on est quand même soutenu par les
résolutions des textes internationaux
qui sont de notre côté c'est que l'état
d'israël se retire des territoires
occupés c'est à dire des trois partis
qui sont annexés g résultat est le
plateau du golan et une partie de la
cisjordanie et qu'on défende un état
autonome palestiniens et que cesse du
côté d'israël tout les campagnes
médiatiques d'extrême droite qui sont
menées et qui aboutissent à des
lynchages des citoyens israéliens arabes
même dans l'état d'israël nous refusons
de terre notre solidarité avec les
palestiniens c'est ce que déclare
plusieurs organisations à l'origine de
cette manifestation dont l'association
des palestiniens en ile-de-france pour
donc justifier le maintien de leur appel
à manifester à 15 heures est ce que
comme les organisateurs vous trouvez que
cette interdiction est injuste et
abusive elle est injuste et les abusif
et les dix trop portionné et les
liberticide elle va créer un précédent
même les personnes qui ne sont pas sur
nos positions par rapport au conflit
israélo palestinien doivent bien
entendre qu'on est en train de créer en
france un espèce de deux phénomènes où
le pouvoir parce qu'il n'est pas
d'accord avec les mots d'ordre d'une
manifestation ou parce qu'il dit qu'il
ne saura pas gérer
d'éventuels débordements interdit le
fait d'exprimer des positions politiques
qui animent pourtant toute la communauté
internationale on parle pas d'un petit
con si j'en parle d'un sujet politique
contre la colonisation qui est majeure
et qui dira depuis des décennies
donc un jour ça vous arrivera un moment
il faut bien comprendre que la macro
n'innove pas se comporter en france
comme sur des territoires occupés un
moment les français qui le souhaitent
ont le droit d'aller se rassembler
pacifiquement les organisations qui
organise ces cortèges ne sont ni en
général pro hamas ni antisémite
elles sont là pour manifestement le
jugement sur votre site vous expliquez
que vous irez à cette manifestation en
sachant qu'elle est aussi soutenu par
des organisations israéliennes quelques
la paix maintenant ou encore goush
shalom qui réclament une reconnaissance
des droits des deux peuples en état
palestinien indépendant aux côtés de
l'état d'israël c'est c'est important
pour vous que des israéliens milite pour
les droits des palestiniens comme vous
mais bien sûr moi je suis marocain et
pourtant je suis pour le sahara libre
c'est pas du tout des sentiments qui
sont animés par une appartenance
nationale au fond de nous certaines
personnes et qui signe deux montants
sont contre les colonies sont contre
l'occupation et par ailleurs j'étais
contente que la manifestation de 2014 on
hésiterait les cortèges soraliens et que
le collectif cheikh yacine qui avaient
des slogans pro bahamas a été maintenue
en dehors du cordon officielle dans ce
moment de toute façon aujourd'hui sont
dissous donc ils ne sont et ne seront
pas là donc c'est sûr manifestation qui
est pour la paix pour
l'autodétermination et l'existence de
ces deux peuples pour le droit à
l'existence d'israël pour le droit à
l'existence de l'état palestinien est
donc
nous ne sommes pas du tout ne
correspondant pas à la caricature qu'ils
on essaye de projeter sur nous pour
discréditer nos positions bien entendu
qu'il ya des israéliens de gauche en
israël qui sont contre l'occupation
israël mais rssi beaucoup fatima benomar
d'avoir répondu à ces questions je
rappelle que vous êtes militante
féministe merci à vous